okay let's go to the phone lines at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go first to our
caller from the 7 2 0 area code who's
calling today from 7 to 0
hey David that me yeah that is hi umm
did be talking to you uh my question is
pretty simple I think we we all know
that nothing
realistically gonna happen to Donald
Trump legally we seen that at this point
in this right office but what I'm
wondering if you think it's realistic
that once he's out of office either in
2020 or 2024 if you think that he's
going to pay any realtor I think that
it's slightly more likely that he might
face legal repercussions after being out
of office than while he is in office but
I think both are extremely unlikely in
total it's sort of like you know when
you hear that eating a certain food
doubles your risk of some condition and
then you realize that it doubles the
risk from 0.2% to 0.4% like either way
it's unlikely even if it doubles I think
it's sort of similar with the Trump
stuff I think that we need to listen I
don't disagree that there are systemic
injustice --is in our sort of framework
of government and the Justice Department
that make it so that really power the
more rich and powerful you are the less
likely it is you will be held to account
for what you do I think that that is an
undeniable reality but it's just not
really likely to happen with Trump and
we need to keep our eye on the ball
which is if possible gaining some seats
in the House and Senate in 2020 and
removing Trump from from office and get
getting him out of there it's you know
it's not nearly as hot as it usually is
it's only like in the high 60s low 70s
which is weird all right go figure
all right thanks for the call appreciate
it